it's Bill Burr and it's time for the
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast just checking in
on you just seeing how your week's going
um I always say this usually I do these
solos
solos I usually do this solo I usually
do this by myself
let me stay within the English language
that I have command of but every once in
a while somebody comes to town and and
and they're amazing and I want to have
them on the podcast and this Thursday is
one of those Thursdays and we're going
to welcome the legendary the one and
only Mr Robert Kelly what's up man hello
Robert it was very professional I know
you was Bobby yes my old roommate yes
I've known you for [__] 30 years has
it been 30 years it has been 30 years
wow I've known you the first night I met
you was in well wait a minute before we
get into that let's get into the
promotion here uh Bobby Kelly is a new
special called kill box that you can
download on Louis ck.com and speaking of
Louis CK Louis CK made an amazing movie
that absolutely [__] love that you
can also download off of Louis ck.com
called Fourth of July starring Joe list
and Robert Kelly yes I loved your
performance thanks buddy in that movie I
want to talk about it but I don't want
to give away your uh we were we were
actually in uh did our first movie
together Bobby this is how well I know
you you have an eyelash and it's really
really make a wish make a wish oh I'm
supposed to make a wish yeah I hope it's
a good podcast
[Laughter]
one of the more intimate things I've
done with you
big eyelash off your [__] dude yeah
we did our first movie together
you me and you did the first time we
were ever on film
in a movie me and you yeah everybody
knows about the koala bear kid it's the
best you can't find it I can't find it I
want it so bad I know you do I want dude
it was so much fun oh you were great in
it you were great too I I kind of you
know
I think my whole in my uh
uh the scene that I did I believe my my
inspiration was Alec Baldwin in that
movie when he went who will protect you
like that's the level I was acting on
somehow we were walking I was following
you down a corridor at Boston University
yep that we were outside you follow me
down outside in a parking lot we both
had full heads of hair and your teeth we
both had full hair and you we had goatee
it was the 90s and I was a drug dealer
you were a drug dealer from another
Southie or Irish guy I was definitely
acting right and you uh you took you
killed me you murdered me
at the end of the movie you shot me no I
didn't 100 100 dude
a hundred percent no I didn't there's no
[__] I would remember if I had a gun
a figure shot me I would be like I'm in
the movies 100 you shot me I didn't dude
a hundred percent
because I just I would bet you a steak
dinner
why are you gonna prove it you got me a
Daytona
give him a steak dinner I can't eat I
killed you in a movie that's so [__]
cool you killed me dude so the end of
the movie I was in with the mob do you
know here's the thing I did the world of
service
I I'm not I'm in trouble with the mob I
get away with that like I find what I
get away with that
get away all right I get away with that
and then I'm walking away like I made it
I did it and there you are and you go
hey something like that and I turn
that's right and you and you have the
gun and you look right at me and you go
boom and and I and I fall and I Die end
of the movie I'm dead so was it two days
I did the quarter and then something
else you did too so I think we had uh
you know because you like did you have
the clips on VHS somewhere me and my mom
has it you who my mom
this is what when we used to live
together
I used to do this all day long he just
says words weird my mom and I'd be like
you what and then he would always do it
the exact way that he said it
that's why you're great you could be a
great voiceover actor yeah get you in a
Pixar movie
um your mom has why does she have it
because I gave her on my [__] when I
moved to when I moved to your apartment
okay I couldn't take anything because it
was so we didn't have any room and you
had [__] we actually had a big living
room we had a big living room but
there's no place to put my [__] it was
everybody's living I came to New York
with a box of [__] just a little box and
some clothes oh Bobby little box though
Bobby little box came to New York
yeah you're [__] you're the Puerto
Rican style it was thin I had the uh the
uh overalls I was wearing overalls like
Greer Barnes oh that's right yeah and
Oshkosh book Bobby yeah I have one
little thing so I gave all my stuff to
my mom and she got she got my artwork
when I used to go to Art School all my
paintings yeah I did I did Art I
remember I was such a troubled inner
city school kid I was a trip you guys
always end up painting and then you die
tragically right as you get cleaned up
you die tragically and then all your
work is worth like a zillion dollars my
work isn't worth it I mean dude I looked
at some of my stuff and I thought it was
so good but it was terrible what was it
uh a still life what is that um the
still life is like no it's like a vase
with an apple and a pear and and you
paint it you know just out of curiosity
yeah like the amount of vases you
actually see in real life why do you
guys always paint a vase and where do
you find vases dude I don't it was in
school it was in in
in art school so I they would have a
vase my the first thing I painted I had
my first charcoal class
um oh you went in deep well you had a
way to charcoal
I was deep brother I was it was a nude
model it said on your schedule nude
model charcoal man or woman I showed up
it was a man I was very sad
um it was it was uncomfortable because
you I was the worst front row and he
yeah
it was a big dong and my first three
drawings because you have you have
minute drawings 30 second drawings uh
and then like 10 second drawings so to
just see the first 15 seconds is look at
that [__] side of that right well the
first three drawings there was no dick I
didn't draw the dick and he walked by
and goes uh Mr Kelly you have to draw
the penis
and he kept coming up ah did he slightly
touch you on the shoulder he slightly he
came up behind me yeah Mr Kelly you have
to draw the penis so I had to draw the
penis yeah it was it was it was a big
one too yeah yeah it was it was
uncomfortable I would think it would be
I wish I said I would have to hang nice
yeah you can't go up with it with the
with the growth that was my move dude
before I did stand up I would pick girls
up because you know I was sober I was
going to meetings and stuff like that
and um I do a charcoal drawing of their
vagina I would I would I would art I
would tell them I'm an artist I'm going
to art school and I would love to draw
you and they'd be like really and I
would get to draw them and and then I'd
we'd hook up
it was like Bobby was legendary that's
just like you know you ever see a great
mixed martial artist and it's like they
can fight standing up on the ground they
could submit ya whatever you want to do
they can go five rounds they can go into
the deep water that was Bobby getting
[__] ass back in the damage dude I
got 90s yeah the 90s 80s 90s yeah I mean
yeah dude you you were yeah it was
Boston Bob was Boston Bob Austin Bobby
was yeah Force yeah the Phoenix used to
write about your experts the phoenix
like three people three old guys from
Boston got that reference they used to
write about Bobby's [__] getting uh
Excavating yeah back in the day it was
fun back in Boston and then when I got
into comedy of course it went over to
Comedy you know what I mean but yeah
drawing was like people girls love
artists man you say I I'd love to draw
you what yeah I want to draw you I'm an
artist now what do you what what is it
about that I want to judge that that
feed into a narcissism do they actually
falsely think that you care about them
as a person what is what is going on
well I think it is yeah it's them
because it's like they're they're you
want to draw me oh yeah you know what I
mean you want to draw me I had a studio
in my basement I lived with my foster
father
in Winthrop and I had a studio
he beat you with a belt no dad I just
wanted to foster dad I just want to
drive I had a father's dad not because I
never gotta make it
me and my mom didn't we couldn't after
rehab we just didn't get along we
couldn't live together it was too much
damage so I had to go I had to go on my
own but I couldn't like I was in school
I didn't have because you put her
through too much or I put it I put it
through too much when I was a juvenile
when I was going in and out of jail and
all that she was just too much my
favorite things you ever said on stage
what's that you were on stage one night
at the cellar
and you were doing some bit or whatever
and this woman the crowd was making a
face and you're like what's what's wrong
with you huh and she goes I don't know
no no he go what's wrong with you she
goes I don't know she goes I just find
you a little crass and you said oh yeah
you were like what what were you doing
when you were 13 huh how are you going
to Junior High you went to the prom blah
blah because you know where I was I was
in jail I was in jail so yeah I'm a
little [__] crass and the whole crowd
laughed and then you continued on and I
remember going like dude that's what you
need to talk about man
need to talk about when you were in jail
man you're right I do I never did I
never did on stage
yeah but I find a lot of people that
actually went through that [__] don't
you know want to revisit it yeah it's
just not something like you know
everybody else is like wow man it's like
a [__] movie and you're like yeah if
you're reading about it but if it
actually happened to you yeah it's like
yeah it's hard to make funny
because and then and then you feel like
you're making fun of it and then there's
kids that are in it you know what I mean
that are still doing it I did
um I do this thing on my podcast once a
year where I raise money for charity
like usually it's at Children's Hospital
one year I huh you raised for what I
raised for charity charity charity
charity and uh one year I did it for the
lockups that I was in and I brought them
an Xbox I brought them clothes I brought
them all this stuff because I remember
when Christmas time comes you don't get
Christmas presents you don't get
anything
um you get bags of [__] that people
don't want and you have to rummage
through it and get a coat and get you
know something out of it
um I remember when I was I was in they
brought in a bag one Christmas I got
that remember guests yeah the upside
down triangle with the question mark in
it yeah uh I I got a fight with a kid
over a guest dungaree jacket because it
was in a bag and we both ran for it at
the same time we both got in trouble and
the juvenile we got like did like lock
up detention in it but I got the jacket
it was a great job it was it acid wash
it was acid wash yeah man with the with
the question mark it was on well worth
the fight was it the big question mark
on the back big question mark on the
back yeah all the guys that like their
parents bought them a cool car yeah and
they were bang in like one of the hot
chicks in my grade like you know there
was only a few of them but like that was
like a status thing if you if you could
afford s genes like first of all there
was like a gene hierarchy okay like the
bottom line was like Gap yep like they
were angler too Wrangler and Wrangler
Gap and Wrangler please bodies that was
all bottom feeder and then you had to
have Levi's yeah it was middle of the
road I'm not trying to encroach right on
your quarterbackness I'm also not a
[__] nerd you had Lee's and then at
the top of the food chain was if you
could uh if you had on guest jeans I was
like dude that kid's Rich yeah guess who
he's like [__] Wicked Rich Jordan Ash
was pretty big too he wears guest jeans
every day dude yeah if you had a guest
angry jacket you were in dude he has
gazelle sunglasses remember the gazelles
yeah Ferraris Ferraris yeah yeah that
well that was a big thing and it folded
up and you zippered it around zipped it
around yeah I knew a guy that that had
all of that [__] and a Volkswagen
Scirocco with a CD player and it was
like it was like mounted you know the
thing always like skipped and I just was
like oh my God that guy's [__]
killing it yeah man you know I had I had
Levi's and an 83 Ford Ranger I love that
Ford Ranger I have a ranger now
oh yeah I have a Ford Ranger now yeah
but the ranger has come along dude the
old Ford Ranger that little truck is the
[__] if you have a four-wheel drive one
I worked in a warehouse and this guy had
the four-wheel drive with the cool
[__] rims yeah and he had it in Gray
and I want to say maybe a little
pinstripe down the side that was a
[__] badass truck it was a badass
truck had a V6 which is all you need
because the truck wasn't that heavy and
it was great four-wheeling and all that
type of stuff uh I want to get one I
want to get one I have the tiny house up
in New Hampshire I want to get uh an old
Ranger like that with just a two doors
and leave it up there just to throw
firewood in The Kayaks and what about uh
over the over the winter where would you
keep it I keep it up there I just get a
car tent
put it over the top of it
don't Bears get into that [__] they
always think there's food no no no no no
no no no no there's food in there
they'll try to get in but there's no
food have you run into Bears Bobby's a
big Outdoorsman He's a fly Fisher I'm an
angle they're called an angular an
angler angler I'm an angler angler yeah
when you go to fly fishing it will say
Anglers only that means fly fishing only
they don't allow the worm fishing people
in are they look down upon because it's
100 they don't have the balls to get in
the river they're garbage people you
know I heard one time there was a guy
it's a an urban myth you know you wear
those big [__] rubber pants yeah he
was doing it in the ocean he waited out
into the ocean and the wave came yeah
and it filled up his [__] pants he'll
die and he died yeah yeah you'll die you
have to like when you uh fly fish I have
a stick why can't you just do this
well you have to Ike you have to care
yeah why can't you just step out of it
like a cartoon dude it's it just sinks
you down you can't get up well yeah you
gotta oh because you can't get your feet
out of the booties nope yeah I carry a
knife yeah tear away [__] rubber
pants like NBA players like getting off
the bench yeah you know I mean you need
that stuff when you go and I don't know
why he's wearing it in the ocean unless
it was cold dude I just remember that
time you had to tear away sweatpants on
when Tony muscata was over
all right Bobby Kelly didn't wear
underwear back in the day for whatever
[__] reason I just was so I forget
what we were doing we were all playing
hooky that day not neither me Tony
mosquito and you none of us had [__]
anything to do that day Tony was coming
down to New York and we were just gonna
[__] hang out and I was it was a
perfect sunny day and and we were
talking about how [__] awesome it was
and Tony's like yeah this is [__]
great I said yeah man it doesn't get any
better than this toys it doesn't get
better than this and you came out with
your Tearaway sweatpants and you go it
doesn't get any better than this
ripped him off thank you
full frontal junk dude me and Tony
[__] died died laughing you just
stood there like that with your dick
hanging out and then you walked that
little city
it was perfect timing I think you were
in the little room yeah don't get any
benefits
but I heard you guys revving it up
I missed that man I miss you know I mean
I love my family I love all that stuff
but I miss those days of just didn't
matter where we were didn't matter what
place didn't what your apartment look it
just we had a place to go and hang to
the point that we went and did our shows
and we were all struggling so we were
focused on that rather than that we were
young and how much [__] fun we were
having I mean we had we had so much
[__] fun I mean ridiculous living up
up there on the Upper East Side dude way
back in the day I mean dude I can't
believe like I was trying to tell
somebody me and used to rollerblade
without brakes
oh we had the hockey ones yeah we had no
breaks yeah can you imagine doing that
now in Manhattan with people texting no
no I used to I used to [__]
rollerblade and then walk down the
stairs of the subway
because I hated taking them off and then
having to put them back on because oh I
know when I used to live on I used to
live on 79th and York that was a nice
apartment and this was before it was a
studio and they slammed a wall and it
called in a [__] one bedroom
apartment and charged me for a one
bedroom then I got to know the chick
upstairs and I never hooked up there
um she [__] had the exact same
apartment above me and hers was a
[__] studio and I was just going like
all right do I have a case here and I
was just like I know where I'm going in
this [__] business I'm not going to
be Petty about this [__] but they were
charging me like 1400 bucks a month
crazy wait this isn't like 2 000 or
something like that for this [__]
thing and I should have been paying like
seven eight hundred right
um but you know I I kind of just let it
go but anyway they didn't have the
Second Avenue subway so you had to go
York these are city blocks York first
second third Lex down two streets 78 77
I remember the [__] but if I put
the rollerblades on I could Breeze over
there but then it was always congested
it was a nice bagel shop right there I
still remember on the uh
you know the north east side of the
street it's a great bagel place there
was just no place to sit down take them
off put them back on so I would
literally [__] walk down the stairs
Holding On The Rail and like you know
you still weren't supposed to do that
but nobody gave a [__] because that's
back when like people were probably
[__] in public
um you know before Giuliani came in and
cleaned it up uh I mean I mean it turned
into a giant Bed Bath and Beyond but and
then we'd get off at Astor Place and
then I would [__] roll the blade over
which was through the park yeah yeah
over to uh the cellar and there was you
know a lot of potholes and [__] like
that but I remember feeling like I'm a
[__] New Yorker here man I'm [__]
rolling well we were man I mean I'm
coming from Boston we would go to what
Nicks Collins we'd run around do spots
and then go to Dominick's every night
yeah I was telling who was I telling
about that
um yeah we used to go there and we do
next and then we go oh fits
I think it was 50. we're talking about
it we go to Dominick's because it would
be like half it would be a couple
hookers or some weird people in us it
was drugs uh musical theater all of
those people getting out of the shows
because it was it was it was weird it
was this weird thing where it was like
the Theater District and hookers and
pimps and comedians would you go into
this pizza place yeah I would go in
there and it was just like I remember
the late great Kevin Knox and gav would
all be posted up over in the corner that
was sort of the Knicks section yeah and
then across the bar was sort of the uh
you know the ladies of the evening or
whatever coming in for like a [__]
drink or whatever and um and then
there's just so sort of weird remember
the big fat guy yeah used to sit out
there in the front one of those guys
whose legs were always like this because
the belly had to lift
um
and we would hang out front too we'd
hang out front sometimes and just I
watched I was eating a slice of pizza
pizza with uh Tony mosquito again and we
watched the O.J Chase it was me Tony and
a cop wow and that was when OJ had the
gun at his head and he was driving down
thing and the cops going he's gonna kill
himself he's going to kill himself watch
this he's gonna kill himself we were
like holy [__] this is [__]
unbelievable it's [__] O.J Simpson
um
anyway but before we go too far back
into like Memory Lane you know we always
where did you uh
shoot this special at dude the special
um
we did it in Saint Pete because Louis
came up to me he's just like Florida
yeah St Pete Florida Tampa Tampa
um and he was he was like I want to do
your special
um I was like yeah he goes where do you
want to do it I go either Boston or
Tampa but I think I I think I wanted to
do it in Tampa because during the
pandemic that that place saved me you
know what I mean I could go down there
and do some shows and actually make some
money oh they completely blew it off oh
they blew it off it was so good dude I
love them
you needed a few states to blow it off
if you didn't have the money to ride it
out if it wasn't for Tampa if it wasn't
for Florida I would have been [__] I
mean and they showed up did you you
should did you thank them in the liner
notes I think 100 that's awesome I thank
Tampa I think Florida it's the State of
Florida yeah because
um and I knew that I had so many fans
that because Mike calters like my my
number one best friend and dude put it
on sale it sold out two shows in five
minutes it was it was just done I was
like because you know I'm like [__] what
if I can't sell it out it's this many
tickets you always get nervous with that
I mean I do and I don't know why you do
do because you're [__] hilarious I
just get I just do and I did and when
they sold out I was like thank you God
that's just such a relief yeah and you
know that too dude you're doing it's all
relative you know you're doing Fenway
Park and it's still like dude
you can't say no to it give me that
Elvis story no because that is the big
thing every Entertainer if they're
playing a [__] shoebox yeah or the
biggest place ever it needs to be sold
out or else you feel like a [__]
loser like you can really play the Roman
Coliseum and if the upper bowl is empty
like oh God yeah I'm sliding down the
back side you know so you think you
think Gladiators with yeah you think
Gladius went through it really dude they
pulled the curtain I'm gonna die in
front of half a [__] crowd here I'm
not killing a lying in front of a line
in front of 10 000 people yeah oh man
that have you ever been there I I woke
up the first time this year yeah I
didn't take it the tour yeah I [__]
hate tours because there's always some
nerd that's just way too into it you
went in by yourself I went by myself me
too and I just [__] checked it out
and I didn't go down yeah because
there's also something weird about that
where it's like I don't want to go down
and what all this suffering happened uh
where the [__] were we one time we
stayed at a hotel
and they used to torture people in the
basement
this it was like it used to be like a
jail or something like that like you can
go down there and blah blah it's like
was that in Boston no this was I don't
know where it was I was doing some run
through Europe okay and it was one of
these [__] buildings from whenever so
anyway the Elvis story so he's playing
somewhere
in Florida or something like that during
I think his fat years or whatever
and uh you know this is like 20 years
after he hit right at this point you got
the Eagles you got James Brown you got
all these [__] guys that are just
like selling crazy tickets Leif Garrett
right you know everything from pop to to
you know that type of [__] Parliament
was coming on so he wasn't selling as
many tickets so he is at this whatever
venue he was at
um they had all the chairs set up and it
didn't sell out wow and that was like a
big [__] thing for him that he he
always asked to sell out man you know
and they would always have to say yes
right so the promoter went in and he got
guys on work release from prison to come
in and take seats out and make it fatter
so they like you know he missed it by
1500 so they took out 1500 seats wow so
when then when he asked he said did I
sell it out man and the guy's like every
seat is full and he's like all right
great yeah great and then he went out
there because I you know I everybody as
a
experience that sure it's uh it's
terrible yeah but that's the thing that
I think makes or break you as a comic
where you learn to not give into that
yep where you go like all right but
these people showed up and I'm gonna
[__] murder them murder so they'll
bring more people and uh you kind of
have to and you have to be able to flip
that switch yourself after a certain
amount of years you can't keep leaning
onto the comics to be like dude am I fun
yeah buddy you're funny yeah yeah you
guys just do it you gotta you gotta
learn to be able to be like like you
know all right you gotta you gotta I
always look at it like the the six round
draft pick you see those guys in the NFL
and they just have a chip on their
shoulder for the rest of their their you
know you didn't think I was [__] good
enough you know I got signed for the
league minimum you got to kind of go
into that mode yeah
um yeah well it's it's you know
I I I I just love that town you know the
people and the crowds are great too my
fans there it's a cigar town too it's a
cigar town it's just a it's just a good
town I like it and they showed up town
yeah it's a [__] casual wear Town
yeah Ybor City gets a little shady at
night but they still got good cigars
during the day they do but I I there's
definitely there's there's I don't know
what hour it is it's somewhere around
between 10 30. it's on 10 30. around 10
30 10 30. it's like I'm too old to be
out here you got to go back to the hotel
and get the [__] out this is this is for
young people I knew that when I came out
I I was doing the Improv over there one
time and I went in at in the afternoon
to do the shows and it was great couples
walking around there was kids I came out
after the second show on a Saturday and
there was a cop with a mesh a mesh shirt
and his badge on the outside
and it was just like just just muscles
like from Miami Vice like some dude I
was like I immediately thought of that
that uh what was that
um Schwarzenegger movie yeah
except that guy wasn't really in shape
no he wasn't he was yeah he was his
original Superman in shape but dude he
dude that's back where if you weren't in
shape they'd get put you gave you a mesh
shirt and fingerless gloves and you
could still have the granny arms they're
like all right that was Barrel chested
in shape right but yeah dude I came out
this cop was sitting there the other guy
had a leather vest on and they were just
these undercover cops that were and just
Anarchy and there was cops on horses
people coming up the street screaming
and getting caught Braveheart it was
nuts dude it was nuts I went back to the
pool uh where the hotel was they had me
in the shitty hotel over there and it
was right off of the street and just how
the cops is going I'm sitting in the
pool with Pete Lee it was Pete Lee it
was the other thing
we would just sitting in the pool scared
because you could hear
and just yeah it was nuts it was crazy
hey people in Tampa they get after it
yeah I can't get mad at that but like
one of the great things though
that I've enjoyed as far as like you
know watching you just keep getting
better and better and also you're one of
the few guys that I know is always a
better person like you're on like the
18th version of Bobby Kelly that is a
better version like most people you know
you meet them yeah 20 years ago you met
him I was just talking about this comic
uh unfortunately passed away David a
Arnold and every time I saw him he was a
better version of himself and there's
like so many people you meet him in 1999
yeah and then you meet him in 2021 and
they're the same [__] guy they just
have a double chin and they're [__]
gray in their beard or whatever and they
look look older but you are always
better but um oh my God I literally
forgot the compliment I was going to
give you no I know what it is sorry my
old brain I'm just patiently waiting is
um
is I feel like you've aged gracefully
where you understand like it's a really
big thing that I feel like especially
people in show business where you kind
of live in that Peter Pan thing yep and
you're old but you don't think you're
old because everybody else is sort of
putting off getting married and having
kids and like uh
you know taking responsibility but like
one of the greatest [__] things is
allowing yourself to be old and getting
the [__] out of the way a young people
get the [__] out of there let them have
their good time don't be the creepy old
guy trying to hang out or ruin their
good time yeah and be like this isn't
music get the [__] away from them find
where the people are of your generation
which is usually home yeah but like you
know it's usually some during the day
[__] like you know they have a wonderful
coffee shop
no it's true but Comics some Comics the
best to me the best part about being a
comic is that we get to do that that
that's a cool thing for us to we can age
gracefully we can just be who we are on
stage now you know what I mean but
remember a lot of people are afraid
afraid of that the thing about aging is
is all you have to do is just say you're
old and then it's out there and then
it's like oh yeah and everybody chills
no it's like coming out all right this
yeah this guy yeah
I'm gay nobody cares I'm in the age
closet yeah man these people that are
like trying to like [__] you know
some people trying to [__] stay young
and it's like it's like dude it's a wrap
yeah you don't have to it's oh it's
[__] you can literally Go on stage
and make fun of yourself and everybody
will embrace it and love you for it and
thank you because they go through the
same [__] yeah like if you do a college
gig and you try to go out there and be
young and cool it is just cringe-worthy
yeah but if you go out there and just
steer into being so much older he
goddamn kids with you [__] scooters
laying around like they love it they
just think you're some idiot yeah
um
no but a lot of people they uh they
don't get to it I have a [__] old
man's sweater now that I love dude I was
just looking at sweaters today I was
gonna with the buttons the button yeah a
jumper is it called I bought it in
Galway Ireland dude every time I put it
on I'm like it's too itchy and once I
just push through that 90 seconds of it
being itchy yeah it's [__] phenomenal
and and and I want my lovely wife
trashes I have one oh
I want one yeah I want a smoker sweater
I can't I have the little the little
Skully cap so I don't catch a cold with
my ball do you really yeah and I just I
just said oh I smoke my cigar yeah and
you know I learned I learn I'm trying to
learn French right I just [__] why
are you trying to learn French
oh you know because uh uh because I I
really want to be in a French
speaking only movie playing a gangster
there's something I've always loved the
language my wife loves it too and we
just like going over there but like I
there's some [__] French actors dude
that I I will put up against
anybody else and I just want to play a
you know somebody I was talking to
somebody about you uh uh because dude
you're like have you ever had your IQ
tested
I'd be afraid to do that dude because
can I just say something
do you you fly a helicopter which is one
of the hardest things to learn how to do
not if I did it what are you talking
about if I can do it dude you rode a
motorcycle dude it's it's way harder
dude because one up five down is not a
harder than a [__] helicopter is it
five times over one down four up I had I
had one up five down oh okay but here's
it's way harder because you have to like
not wipe out why there's people it's not
like there's people texting while flying
next to me and I'm like dude
you're up there maybe you're falling
you're falling hundreds of feet
no you enter in auto rotation what is it
what do you mean
you just go
in theory I mean granted
[Applause]
the second it happens you slam the
collective down and you [__] yank the
cyclic back and to keep your RPMs up
because that's the only thing keeping
you alive you pick your [__] spot if
you're coming in too fast you turn
sideways you had some [__] traffic
and you yell out the window
no cars no cars no cars we're right
through an intersection that's a hockey
stop
uh motorcycle you just go you have no
you're just going
no you wipe out on the road and then you
roll over and look up hurt [__] truck
runs you over just your legs and you're
like yeah
trying to crawl off on your elbows
and then somebody else comes by and you
know you know you live uh you live
that's the worst
yeah
dude you know how bad I want a
motorcycle I I just want like I I really
uh I love it's weird I have a like
a weird taste in motorcycles I love to
[__] Ducatis but I also love a Harley
Road King right so I I want like you
know I want to be comfortable as an
American yeah at some point you have to
ride a [__] road I'm gonna get I'm
gonna get a trike
I'm gonna get this Bobby Kelly everybody
Bobby Kelly Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast he
has a kill box
Fourth of July he loves Tampa and he
wants to get a trike dude have you seen
the trikes do you know what I'm talking
about listen you can get a trike if you
rode a motorcycle for 30 [__] years
and you have the stories and then you
have that big [__] I wrote a Harley I
and you're in your 60s and I get it I
don't like okay I don't want to [__]
tip over
I get it all right all right but you had
a Honda Shadow
you have not earned a [__] trike I'm
sorry all right we're gonna do you're
right you're right you're right every
time I love you Bob you push me you're
right you're right no you make it good
all right I'm gonna do you want to hear
something funny if you want to listen to
me read out loud okay here's the
advertising here it's solo stove Bob I
have one this stove I love owners I have
it serial killers love this you know
after a [__] murder they can sit
there by themselves
that's the last one I ain't doing this
anymore is that the copy no it's not the
copy all right solo stove everybody you
know there's something special about
fall that brings us closer together and
with the smokeless fire pit it is dude
this thing should be on The Price is
Right with one of those hot chicks it is
smokeless one of the in-shaped guys they
have now yeah because they're
Progressive but why do they keep all
those toxic old games Bob
um creating those moments is easier than
ever enjoy all the warmth and comfort of
a fire pit this is great for watching
college football outside away from your
wife smoking a stick plus portability
quick setup and cleaning and best of all
no smoke no smoke no smoke no smudging
it no picking up the chair your
neighbors aren't complaining and moving
around yeah it's good for La that's
right keep your shoulders down though uh
summer may get all the excitement but
nothing beats The Great Outdoors during
the fall upgrade your backyard with the
solo stealth fire pit and create story
worthy moments without the Fireside
fumes I thought I said without the
female fumes stainless steel
construction designed to regulate
airflow and burn more efficiently so
little so a little smoke you wonder how
is there so much fire solar Stove fire
pits are brilliantly engineered to be
easy to use and they're built to last
easy and to light you get it man they're
[__] awesome prepare for your best uh
Outdoor Memories yet and save big during
the solo stove fall event plus use promo
code you are at solostove.com to get ten
dollars off that solar stove
solostove.com promo code bird for ten
dollars off the fall event deals all the
big college games are coming up this is
the stove for you all right here we go
Master Class Bob all right Master Class
everybody Master Class
this we never send that part of it
tonight they just show the read Master
Class Master Class brings you inside
uh the minds of the most qualified
people in all areas of life with Master
Class you can learn from the world's
best Minds anytime anywhere and at your
own place uh you can learn French pastry
fundamentals oh flaky crust how do you
do that well let's talk to Jacques
from Dominique Ansel improve your
writing skills from David Mamet David
Mamet will literally tell talk to you or
Judy Bloom she wrote all his books that
the chicks read on the beach or learn
space exploration from an astronaut
Chris Hadfield
Chris Hadfield I mean he's going to
teach you how to go into space that
sounds like something else sounds like
you need an app or something how do I
get up there
you need a helicopter you get your own
rocket yeah Chris will tell you how to
do it uh with over 150 classes from a
range of world-class instructors that
thing you've always wanted to do is
closer than you think I highly recommend
you check it out get unlimited access
every to every class as a Monday Morning
podcast listener you get 15 off an
annual membership do they have drummers
on that too man oh really it's
incredible go to masterclass.com that's
masterclass.com and get 15 off
masterclass
all right this is the last one Simply
Safe Simply Safe Simply Safe isn't that
what we all want to be we want to be
simply I feel safe with you Bobby I
don't want to be hard safe I want to be
Simply Safe yes I don't want to be
complex safe no complex safe the wrong
word hard was the wrong word you're
correct complex we both went to summer
school yes all right if you thought
about protecting your home and security
but haven't been waiting for the right
time
what if you thought about protecting
your home with security but have been
waiting for the right time you'll want
to listen up all right quit your chatter
here comes some information you can use
right now listeners of my show can get
40 off simply saves award-winning home
security Not only was simply safe do it
better simply say thank you uh name the
the best home security of 2022 by U.S
news and World Report I use and Trust
Simply Safe to protect my own home and
my family because at SimpliSafe your
safety is the only thing that matters
it's great I feel like I'm doing the
news here uh when a threat is detected
Simply Safe monitoring professionals
promptly contact you and dispatch First
Responders to your home even if you're
away or unable to respond uh it's a lot
there
24 7 Professional monitoring
24 7.
monitoring costs just under a dollar a
day that's less than half the cost of
adt's traditional professional installer
plan Simply Safe blankets your home
security imperfection in protection with
Advanced sensors for every room window
door and HD uh security cameras for
inside and outside your home bonus too
you can see all the varmints that walk
along the side of your house and try to
get into your uh trash can trash cans
yeah little [__] back and forth
between coyotes and raccoons you have
your own nature show smarter ways to
detect motion that only alert you when a
threat is real and even Hazard sensors
that instantly detect fires floods and
other threats to your home don't miss uh
one time this guy was making a frozen
pizza and he fell asleep he was probably
doing drugs and uh that's simply safe
saved his ass no [__] he would have died
because of an Elio's [__] grandmother
slice don't miss this chance to save big
when you promote protect your home with
the best get 40 off your order when you
visit simplysafe.com I'm slash bird
today customize the perfect system for
your home in just a few minutes that's
simplysafe.com there's no safe
like SimpliSafe right
well that was good very important it was
great it wasn't bad it was great you
just have to see me excited so I can't
get a trike
I can't well
I'll wait till I'm 60 something I think
that was the plan anyways
because me and Don wants I think my wife
is into bikey guys
she likes that tattooed guy she likes
motorcycle guys I think I'm a kid dude
you should get a trike without the
two-tiered seat this is a two-tiered
seat we just go cruising on the bike you
know what it'd be fun who makes it
um a Harley makes one Honda makes one
I'm sorry I didn't hear the second one
Harley makes one that's yes they do
thank you America stop thank you yes sir
stop right there right you know you're
gonna get a Japanese trike and ride
around New Hampshire good luck to you
sir
live free a drive and you're going to
come out there in a Honda Trike
today I'm
out here
valid boy
to call you more often Shinola a shy no
American-made watch right in Detroit
boom what do you got uh Sky dweller
Rolex that sorry man Jesus Christ look
at that thing [__] Kevin Hart in the
goddamn building here yeah shiny there
all right well Bob usually I would
continue to talk but we're gonna go
smoke a cigar we're gonna go smoke a bat
we're gonna go smoke we're gonna get a
little lunch first all right whatever
you want to do okay yeah a little just a
little something a little something just
because you smoke a bat with nothing in
you you get a little sick you get a
little sick yeah you know where we're
going yeah I'm very excited dude all
right uh thanks for having me in dude
it's good to see you yeah great seeing
you and I know you do this by yourself
so it's an honor to uh have you in the
studio yeah and you know what I actually
made a dream come true that I finally
did an infomercial with you I've always
wanted to do that I never told you that
I never felt close enough I'm glad this
version of me made you feel comfortable
enough to tell me that dude sorry now
we're creeping everybody up Bobby Kelly
everybody check out killbox you can get
it on Louis ck.com and check out a
really I [__] cannot say how much I
love that movie Fourth of July if you're
really just into just a great [__]
movie that is just perfectly executed
yeah directed by Louis CK starring The
One and Only uh Bobby Kelly and Joe list
uh Fourth of July on Louis ck.com kill
box shot in your favorite City Tampa
Florida Tampa shout out to them uh that
is it uh have a great weekend you [__]
and I'll check in on you no no I'll see
you on Monday
there we go
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
the Monday Morning podcast for Monday
October 27th 2014.
how the [__] you doing
uh I'm actually recording this thing
late I'm recording it late and then I
gotta go to work I gotta go to work oh
Billy day job Oh Billy day job Oh Billy
burning into both ends
you know
something's got to give
why does it always have to be us
why don't you put your work first
um anyways uh I don't know what the [__]
that was I am sitting here as you can
tell by the echo echo echo maybe you
can't hear it but I can hear it I'm
sitting in my living room
because I'm doing this Monday morning
8 30 my time so this is still a Monday
Morning podcast where I'm from
despite all you selfish douchebags
around the globe
around the planet
you know and people do that thing
they'll notice on this beautiful blue
sphere that we call Mother Earth I just
well let me know when somebody gonna lie
to you
they start shaking their head when
they're giving the speech I want to
thank everybody for Gathering here today
well I gotta tell you that you know what
we got coming often they start shaking
their [__] head you know
trying to Charisma their way through
[__]
stealing all the tax dollars
anyways
I didn't do I didn't do [__] this
weekend I didn't do any stand-up
did I no
I didn't I just [__] stayed in trying
to catch up on my goddamn sleep here
but I've been doing stand-up during the
week and I got a big stand-up gig coming
up I'm doing uh the 20th
um annual uh Comics come home benefit
for uh Cam Neely the Cam Neely house uh
put together by Dennis Leary and the
always adorable Jimmy Serpico always
adorable
I challenge you to find a picture of Jim
Serpico where he doesn't look absolutely
adorable that is an adorable middle-aged
man
um I got that coming up so I got to make
sure I'm on my game because I'm going to
be following a bunch of monsters I think
I'm going on last you know
and that is the deal on those things you
don't headline one of those you go on
last because you're going on after all
headliners
so
um there's not a lot of meat left on the
bone if you know what I mean
I can't really see myself 10 comics in
being able to bring up Ebola and it's
still a fresh topic if you know what I
mean right
that's why I'm doing a bit on the mumps
yeah
the Forgotten one
dude I gotta be honest with you I am so
[__] sick of all these diseases
grandstanding during Sports
in every [__] place you go like it's
it's all this this goddamn they're
marketing diseases now because they're
trying to get your money for research
somewhere in there I know there's a good
thought like they're trying to cure the
disease but there's a lot of lexuses
Lexus is this is being bought off of
that money you can't tell me that there
isn't because I don't give a [__] how
much you give a [__] about stopping a
disease at some point you want a nice
house and you want a nice car and if all
you do is try to find a cure for that
[__] thing at some point you're
dipping into the aspirin fund right
Jesus [__] Christ the combination of
this and and the and the the [__]
getting reprimanded when you watch a
football game no more no more no more go
[__] yourself I'm not hitting anybody
the [__] off my TV
you [__] dopes what do you think of
some wife beater at home who's gonna see
the commercial and then be like oh okay
you're just gonna erase 20 years of bad
parenting with some dumb [__]
commercials with your black shirts on it
drives me up the [__] wall
you're talking to me like I'm two years
old and you're also talking about this
this major [__] problem as if it's
like you know why don't you just [__]
hire one of those planes with the banner
across it and just tell Society how the
[__] they're supposed to behave I'm sure
that'll solve something too
yeah yeah that just [__] drives me
nuts the whole [__] thing drives me
up the [__] wall stand for cancer and
everybody's standing up with the name of
somebody that they had all right who
doesn't want to stop cancer
who doesn't give to it
do you got to interrupt a [__] the
World Series to remind me that there's
people dying of cancer Sports is
supposed to be my Safe Haven
thank you
maybe Mike Golic was right I mean I mean
I mean I mean
that's why Mike Golic
that's why my goalie that guy is a
stammering jackass
you know you know you're dumb when you
have to constantly bring up the smart
school you went to
I know a lot of you guys are thinking
right now Bill have you been smoking a
lot of cigars lately is that what for
the uh the cough I have not
all right old freckles here actually
went I've gone eight days without a
cigar and now it's out of my system
I don't crave it right now
I let the humidor dwindle down
is that the right word humidor
I say humidifiers for your voice
humidors for cigars
and humidity
is that thing that people who don't
understand weather
get mad at when somebody says it's it's
not the heat it's the humidity and then
they go oh that's that's like saying
it's not the bullet it's the gun no it
isn't no it isn't if you [__] read up
on humidity you dumb [__] if you got out
of the East Coast or down south and you
headed out west and you felt a dry Heat
versus that ungodly [__] moisture
that is in the air when you have
humidity
you know
basically what happens is is when you
have hot air that's that's what's known
as a low pressure system
and the molecules get larger
it really doesn't always if it's there's
just really no moisture
you know like if you live near a [__]
desert it doesn't make a difference how
[__] hot it is there's no [__]
moisture to extrapolate
you know and bring into that [__] air
is essentially what's going on
okay that's why it's awesome to [__]
live out here now I don't understand we
live near a [__] ocean I don't
understand how some of that water
doesn't get in the air but God knows it
doesn't
it does not
we live right near the Mojave Desert I
don't know what it is no Santa Ana winds
comes down through the [__] Canyon I
think it just dries everything the [__]
out like a giant hair dryer so when
you're out here and it's 90 degrees I
mean it feels more like when you walk to
your car that God has a microscope not a
microscope a [__] magnifying glass
right on the top of your skull
right
as opposed to when you're back east and
so it's like one part of your body's
just like oh my God I gotta get in a
[__] car as opposed to when you're
back East where you're just walking out
with your arms to this you know straight
out
like you got something like you're
nailed to some invisible cross just
walking down the street like
you just can't escape it
you take a shower and two seconds later
you're all [__] soaking wet again
Bill we understand it all right I didn't
explain it well but I'm a [__] anyways
um
and coming
you hear that
Jesus Christ that [__] plane is close
these [__] people out here are are
lunatics
the way they fly there's [__] people
in helicopters and airplanes they fly
like 800 feet above the [__] ground
it's just like where are you gonna put
that thing if God forbid you had a
[__] engine failure
huh you're gonna try and land here with
all the [__] wires
I'm all over the place
I need to focus here
um
anyways I had another big sit down with
my uh
my contractors and all that type of [__]
we're finally uh
on our way here we're on our way
we're finally getting to the final uh
I'd say 20 of the job that's how [__]
up my downstairs was
slash all the other [__] that
happens when you're building something
um you know
you know what kills me is right up the
street some lady bought a house
and gutted the whole [__] thing and
she has workers over there seven days a
goddamn week however I know what they're
doing over there they're flipping a
[__] house
I'm not flipping a house I'm having 100
quality
you should see you should see the
[__] Plumbing I got in down there
all copper piping oh it's just fine it's
gorgeous it's almost it's almost a
[__] shame that they're gonna close
up the walls that's how [__]
beautiful the work is that's been done
downstairs and
this house used to basically be a house
on top and a tree fort down below it is
now an absolute [__] Fortress
and someday when I go to sell this thing
I can I can look the person in the eye
that I'm going to sell this to
as opposed to the [__]
I don't even know I honestly think the
people who lived here before are just I
don't think people even understand some
of them some of them are actually out to
[__] you over
okay
like whoever put that [__] Tarpon
downstairs to hold back four feet of
dirt
or I mean four feet high level of
[__] dirt
or maybe three feet I don't [__] know
all I know now is I got a concrete
barrier going all the way around like
I'm supposed to everything's up to code
I had a master electrician come in
rewire the whole [__] place I got
copper piping going through all the gun
we chased the pipe all the way up as far
as we could go you know there's a few
galvanized pipes sections of it here or
there but generally speaking
um you know this house is going to be uh
it's going to be Rock Solid and I've I
was actually
so [__] depressed with how long that
this [__] has been taking
that um last night I actually went on
the uh the internet and I was looking at
other houses like [__] this I'm out you
know you know like when you're in a
relationship with someone that you just
love okay so you can't break up with
them but every once in a while you just
start thinking you know what if I just
went out and I bought a [__] Corvette
you know and I just got a scarf or some
[__] and just started driving around and
just lived for me I started doing that
with my house last night and I just
looked at all the other houses and it's
just like
I can see it I can see it in all the
houses I like I like old houses and
every one of them now I don't see the
beautiful house with all the character
anymore you know what I see I see wood
rot I see cloth wiring I see galvanized
pipe I see a gas leak
you know that's that's all I see I see a
[__] new roof I see flashing that
wasn't put in properly I see all of that
that's all I see now
that's all I see I see the cracks
you know on the walls
knowing that you know I see windows that
aren't going to close [__] prop but
that's what I would do now when I walked
in
to a house have I looked at a house now
I would start opening closing windows I
checked the water pressure I'd go under
the house you know smell for gas and all
of that type of [__] now you know
something as much as I did all of that
I'd still get [__] because you can't
stick your head in a wall and you have
no idea what the [__] in there you got
no idea you've got no [__] idea how
many times over the course of the life
of that house some [__] varmint or
some goddamn rodent got into the [__]
wall chewed on what left a bunch of
[__] [__] pellets I'm telling you
it's horrific the only thing you can do
is maybe buy uh a brand new house a
house that was uh just bought in case
you don't know what brand new means and
then even then I don't know something's
gonna [__] happen
you know
I don't know I'm soured on the whole
[__] thing and I put my goddamn life
savings into downstairs and I don't
think I'm ever leaving
that's it I'm [__] done all I need is
a friend with a pool and I'm good
I put in the floors in downstairs which
is [__] exciting and Dusty all at the
same time
so anyways um this is the Monday Morning
podcast my name is uh William Burke
being very official
this week and uh yeah I didn't do [__]
this week um oh for those of you for
those of you who are on the internet
this week and you might have saw uh we
finally announced the show that I've
been telling you that I've been writing
on
um I actually sold an animated
show to Netflix a cartoon as I like to
call them everybody calls it it's an
animated show it's animation it's a
cartoon I sold a cartoon to Netflix uh
they greenlit six episodes so this is a
real thing this is coming out it's
comment
out
um
uh the name of the show is called f is
for family and it's about a family in
1974.
all right it's basically I'm animating
my childhood Stories the people that I
kind of grew up with uh nobody's uh in
particular just sort of the way [__] was
back then and I'm working with a bunch
of great people who all kind of grew up
in that era too we all kind of had the
same moms and dads and friends and
neighbors and all that type of [__] so
uh
it's not gonna lie to you it's the most
work I've ever done in this business but
also what has been the most fun of
anything that I've ever done and I can't
wait for you guys to see it
unfortunately
because it is animation it's not going
to be out until a year from December
which coincidentally enough I think is
when they're going to finish the bottom
of my house so it's all going to come
together for me next year next year in
2015 December
come Santa Claus Here Comes Santa Claus
write down Santa Claus Lane Billy's
basement is [__] finish and he's got
a show please [__] watch it please
[__] watch it so I make money
and then I'll have to buy a roof all
right um so that's coming out yeah
a year from this December is when it's
coming out I don't know why they
announce it as soon as they do but uh we
got a great cast we got Laura derns
going to play my wife Justin long is
playing my son
uh David keckner is playing my boss and
uh they're all absolutely [__]
hilarious and we got a bunch of other
people
um doing voices on there and uh like I
said it's the most fun I've I've other
than doing stand-up it's the most fun
I've had I can't wait for you guys to
see it because I think it's going to be
pretty [__]
is pretty over the top put it that way
um
and I know what you're thinking well
Bill how did you come up with an idea
like that well you know what I used to
tell my childhood stories on stage and
only Twisted people would laugh and the
rest of the crowd be like wow oh that's
sad
so I was walking my dog one day trying
to think how the [__] can I do these
things
where people will uh you know [__]
loosen up a little bit I was like all
right I'll animate it I'll do a cartoon
those aren't real people they have three
[__] fingers on each hand
and then nobody can get mad nobody can
get offended and that's been the most
fun about doing this as we've been
writing this thing at no point have I
got one network note
saying well what is it what are we
promoting drug use that's violence
against women this is you know what's
Peter gonna say no no nothing because
it's cartoon people it doesn't [__]
count
um so there you go so I got that coming
out I know it's a long ways off but I'm
excited about it so I'll be talking to
you we've recorded uh
you know some episodes at this point you
know we're about halfway done and um
I can't I I you know I've just been
having the time of my life doing it so
that's what I've been doing
all right and with that let me read a
little bit of advertising here let's pay
for the [__] basements here
um all right sorry guys the [__]
throat I know it's annoying all right
DraftKings everybody let's listeners are
winning huge cash prize cash prizes
every week at draftkings.com America's
favorite one week fantasy football site
one week fantasy means no season-long
commitments play whenever you want got a
ninja player not a problem at DraftKings
where it's like a new season every week
so you're never stuck with the same
players Rex Ryan ought to play this huh
poor bastard uh pick your team in
minutes and you could be on your way to
winning instant cash last year one
player turned 11 bucks into four grand
another one 100 Grand his first time
ever playing and another one a million
bucks in one day just playing fantasy
football hurry and get free hurry and
get free entry into the 100 000 fantasy
football contest this weekend where
first place takes home 10 grand call to
action
head over to DraftKings now and enter
the promo code defense to play for free
draftkings.com bigger events bigger
winnings bigger millionaires into
defense for free entry now now at
draftkings.com draftkings.com that man
right there draftkings.com
Dollar Shave Club everybody guys
dollarshaveclub.com I've been talking
about them for years
they deliver great raises for a few
bucks a month if you're not a member
what shall hold up what are you waiting
for what do you like old ladies you want
to go down to the CVS and stand behind
them huh smelling that creep and death
or do you want fresh Racers delivered to
your door every week once a month
look I think they'll have a bunch of
fees hit you with a bunch of fees if
that's what's worrying you don't worry
dollarshaveclub.com has no fees you just
pay for raises the raises that they ship
you and that's it get their four blade
razor and four replacement blades sent
to your door each month for six bucks
including shipping
you don't want to get locked into a
monthly commitment we understand
dollarshaveclub.com doesn't have any
contracts
It's all under the table dude and if you
decide you don't want raises for a month
or two they won't send any and you don't
pay a dime they're basically running
their business the way they should be
don't know if you'll like their products
I already told you their stuff is
amazing but if you don't if you don't
agree dollarshaveclub.com will refund
your money no questions asked
[Music]
um stop with the excuses unless you're
some idiot who likes wasting money go
sign up at dollarshaveclub.com right now
I'm telling you it's great that's
dollarshaveclub.com where was that when
I was a child
a child when I was first starting to
to shave you know how much money I've
[__] blown
on razors I don't I don't even want to
know how do you want to know it's too
scary
all right
[Music]
NFL football talk
to all the ladies just you know walk
away from the podcast at this point all
right
go make some goddamn pumpkin pie you
know go put on an apron and some
Horseshoes and walk around the kitchen
like you used to when relationships
worked okay
before you were [__] moaning and
complaining at me during the football
both from the kitchen and on my
television set oh Jesus Bill Jesus
let's talk about
um
let's talk about my New England Patriots
huh how'd you like that Chicago
huh that was for Super Bowl 20.
I hate when people do that when they
think that you can get revenge for a
playoff game playoffs a playoff game
during the regular season
um foreign
I'm going to go out on a limb and say uh
that was just a bad game for Chicago
I'm not saying they would have won the
game but come on that was [__]
ridiculous the the end the final like
five minutes of the second quarter there
should have been no announcers they
should have just been playing Benny Hill
music anytime the [__] Bears had the
ball
you know we scored 21 points in like
four and a half minutes it was I didn't
I didn't even watch the second half put
it that way
put up a 50 spot on them
five zero and you know what as much as I
want to rub it in their face who beat
who in the Stanley Cup finals who beat
who in the Super Bowl exactly
there you go
there you go so no Chicago fan should
feel sad there's not one Chicago fan out
there that should feel sad you guys have
had a lot of success you had Michael
Jordan right 85 Bears the Bears is a
little rough you know but you got the
the Blackhawks are making up for it and
all you Cub fans I don't have you guys
do you you don't even care you started
caring when some [__] nerd wearing a
Walkman touched a foul ball and you all
piled on him like like the [__]
[__] you are
Chicago Cub fans what about the other
six guys standing around who also
reached up for the ball what's the
matter were they out of your weight
class you wanted that guy with his
little hat pulled down over his head
you [__] punks I don't have any
sympathy for Chicago Cubs fan because
they don't even give a [__] they've only
given a [__] for like the last 10 years
but other than that it's just been take
your shirt off and let's have a keg
party nobody cares
they're almost like an honorary baseball
team like yeah you know just this
represent the fact that people like the
game
you know the White Sox fans they care
they give a [__] it's written all over
their goddamn faces you know they still
miss their old ballpark they hate that
new place you see them coming in with
their heads down going look at this
stupid ass [__] thing you know
we had a classic [__] car and we
traded it in on a Ford Taurus what the
[__] did we do you know so you can feel
for those guys they give a [__] Chicago
Cub fans do not give a [__]
all right so if you're a tourist if you
ever go to Chicago
and you run into somebody
you know and they got a passion for what
they're doing that's a White Sox fan if
you run into just some [__] jerk off
you know sitting there wearing loafers
with no socks
you know and some silly [__] let's
play two hat that is a Cubs fan
and they are not to be respected
see what I did there people
not only did we just beat them I just
caused hopefully some arguments right
now between people in Chicago
that right there was a terrorist act
right here in the podcast and you listen
to it because you didn't do anything
because you didn't hit stop you actually
became a part of it and now you're
liable what do you think about that all
right um I actually you know as well as
the Patriots are playing and they look
great how the [__] are we number one in
past defense I had no idea I've been
watching every game
um I would say and it would like last in
the run or some horseshit like that so
I I actually think
this next week when we play the Broncos
you know if we win
um decisively then I'll actually believe
in this team as far as their ability to
possibly uh
you know go deep into the playoffs
and maybe make a run at this thing but I
got to be honest with you who the [__]
is good this year in the NFL
who's like like without a doubt [__]
good
like look at the [__] Seahawks I
don't know what the hell happened to
them
they won like four games this year I
don't know how many games we're into at
this [__] point what are you eight
weeks in
let me try to pull this [__] up here
the standings
um
like I would have thought the Steelers
were gonna we're gonna lose
who the [__] were they playing I don't
even remember
I'm the horse why do I do this [__]
where the [__] are the Seahawks
Seattle Seahawks are four and three
you're telling me the Arizona Cardinals
six and one like as a Patriots fan I
gotta sit there and think if we make it
to the Super Bowl holy [__] we might
play the Cardinals
look out for those lions
I'm not even buying the Eagles
I I don't believe in their coach or
their quarterback I don't think I don't
know that anybody's good the Giants are
three and four
I don't know a little Raiders oh and
seven Broncos are six and one
I think they could actually uh I don't
know
I think we would we would have a tough
time obviously with the Broncos we'd
have a tough time with the Colts I don't
get the Bengals
I don't get them
everybody was talking about how they
were [__] unbelievable and then they
came into Foxboro and got the living
[__] kicked out of them it's Cincinnati
they're never going to win anything did
you ever just look at a uniform you're
just like that you're done you're never
going to win a Super Bowl the Cincinnati
Bengals
it's [__] over they look like they're
remember that that Broadway show cats
that's what they if you put a helmets on
those [__] dancers
to dream The Impossible Dream
you know they could do that
why am I being a dick
you know what because I gotta I gotta
[__] blow through this podcast and I
gotta go to work and I'm [__] I'm I'm
I'm I'm not in day job shape I haven't
had a day job since 1995 and I got to
get up every morning pack a [__]
lunch like a jerk off I'm just [__]
with you guys with all your teams
um I actually feel really bad for the
Raiders man oh it's seven what the [__]
I watched a little bit of that game
yesterday how about that Browns defense
huh their offense sucks one guy goes
down on the o line and all of a sudden
everybody rolls over
the [__] Pockets collapsing
11 they're going yeah I know it was a
major injury really so then everybody
sucks on the offensive line I don't
understand that but that defense looked
phenomenal but granted they were playing
their 80s
um all right let me just get let me bail
out of this I obviously don't know [__]
about football this year despite the
fact that I've watched almost every week
oh I see movement is that the lovely Nia
the lovely Nia
hey what's oh I just get the wave
she's coming in
um
anyways oh you know what I did yesterday
although over the last two days because
it's uh it's Halloween you know me I get
up for the holidays I think it's very
important
to uh start Traditions around the
holidays you know what I mean it reminds
you childhood you create new memories
right so I made six loaves of pumpkin
bread
I've been handing them out to my friends
like a [__] drug dealer you know
because they're wrapped in foil it just
feels like you got a brick of weed you
know riding around in my my [__] I'm
riding around in a Prius
with one of those uh uh save the Earth
grocery bags the cloth ones filled with
pumpkin bread dropping it off to friends
okay
if you can be any more effeminate and
still be straight
if you can top that I want to know what
it is
that's your homework this week I want
you guys to send me in emails that you
you feel that there's something Beyond
driving a Prius with a cloth grocery bag
filled up with pumpkin bread that you
made
dropping it off to friends
and I want you to find something that's
more effeminate than that as a straight
guy
and don't just tag on to what I just
said and add like skipping you know what
I'm gonna [__] just go hack up
whatever the [__] is in my hang on a
second hang on well let me just hit
pause here
all right I'm back sorry about that
Jesus Christ I should have done that 20
minutes ago
I can't imagine how many listeners I've
lost
um all right what am I talking about oh
yeah making the pumpkin bread dude I got
it down now you make six loaves of
pumpkin bread you can do that [__] in
your sleep
I found this giant [__] whisk
that we got
as a wedding gift
you know uh my wife registered it you
know you know they always registered all
that that [__] that you think as a guy
you think is dumb
like why do we need all this you know
why don't we register at the flat screen
TV store we don't do that yeah
you register it like Wicks and sticks
you know get a bunch of [__] candles
you know glasses and plates and all of
that [__] and uh then all of a sudden it
arrives
and you're like ah Jesus Christ you got
to cut all this [__] up and then next
thing you know you got a stocked [__]
kitchen
and you're looking at that big dumb
stupid [__] whisk
going what look at this side I want to
make it a [__] uh make some pancakes
for the Green Giant what I need a wish
this big for I'll tell you when you need
it when you're making six loaves of
pumpkin bread
and you're standing on a [__] chair
just stirring that
stirring that [__] I gotta admit I
[__] love bacon it's just it's like
controlled like playing in like a mud
puddle it's like you're being a little
kid again
and I gotta tell you it's delicious and
I ate a bunch of it and uh
I'm not liking the shape I'm in right
now I'm [__] Billy fat again right
now
it's [__] driving me nuts and uh
I gotta start working out again and
someone told me the other day what are
you talking about you look good you look
good it's like no no I don't I have a
shirt on
most people look good when you put
clothes on them
you know when you when you're when
you're hiding the mistakes
and that's basically how you stay in
shape
you know every night before you go to
bed you take your shirt off and you look
at it
you look at the damage that you created
in the mirror
and you do every sort of Bend you can
possibly Bend to the side Bend to the
other side right
stand to the side
you know bend over at the waist and you
just see that [__] spare tire
just grab a whole [__] handful of it
look at you you [__] piece of [__]
huh how about a little willpower
that first half was [__] we're gonna
get out there in the third quarter you
can [__] psych yourself up
you psych yourself up it's all about the
next goddamn day when you wake up in the
morning that's like you're coming out of
the locker room at halftime all right
and what are we gonna do we're going to
make some halftime adjustments are we
going to go right back to the Frosted
Flakes huh what are you gonna do you're
gonna make some red velvet pancakes you
tub of [__]
are you gonna get some grape nuts and
have a banana
I'm gonna make some oatmeal that's what
you need to do you got to get the
[__] oatmeal
what is that [__] that I'm telling you
dude it's it's
it's a it's I I used to never believe
that food is a drug it's 100 a drug and
you gotta [__] when you start eating
badly
you gotta force yourself to just [__]
eat a salad and it just [__] stops
those Cravings like dead in the track
it's a [__] it's a stiff arm right to
the sugar salt [__] you know same
thing with working out I didn't work out
for like at least like 10 days and I
kept sitting on the couch as I'm
watching sports going bill just [__]
drop the floor and just give you know
bang out 100 push-ups and I just I I'll
do it tomorrow I don't feel like it you
don't because I've been eating like [__]
I'm eating pumpkin bread I got that [__]
in my body and it's it's [__] eating
away at my brain
and as is is the Smart part of me is
going gone Bill get up go for a walk you
paste the type of [__] right
the pumpkin the pumpkin Bread's getting
stronger it's in there
this guy don't listen to him sit on the
couch come on you earned it you've been
working hard right
so yesterday I finally got off the couch
and my body's screaming no I don't want
a dog
and I just forced myself
and within five six of them you know you
get that you start getting that Rush
that you're working out
you know you stand up after what a
banging out a set of 25 35 or whatever
right
you get up and all of a sudden you feel
good you start strutting around
you know
first down right like you just made a
nice [__] catch on third down saving
the drive
you drop down you do another 35 you
start thinking dude I'm gonna get
[__] shredded
huh I'm gonna wear that Mark Wahlberg
[__] underwear walking around all
shredded right you start thinking [__]
like that just after two sets
but if you didn't override that [__]
McDonald's in your brain and you just
sat there you know what you're gonna do
you're going to add another [__]
layer of fat
and you're gonna go into the bathroom at
night hang in your head when you brush
your teeth because you know you don't
want to look at it now you got a t-shirt
on you can see it coming through your
[__] t-shirt you can't hide that [__]
right
that big pile of mush clinging to your
[__] rib cage
awful
looking like a [__]
I don't know what I'll get to a certain
level of shape I just feel like I should
be tied to the wrists hanging from a
tree and be used as a pinata
foreign
candy comes out of my ass because I've
been eating so bad I'm sorry whatever
what do you want from me so now I'm back
on the stick so you know all I did was I
did 100 push-ups
and uh I woke up today thinking about
doing pull-ups
I not done that
I'd be [__] out there eating pumpkin
bread now I'm not gonna lie to you I'm
slice of it
on butter on it
all right but you just got you know you
just gotta refuse to get past
a certain point
you have to have a [__] Line in the
Sand a line in the butter well you're
just like I'm not going past this
I'm not going past this [__] so
you know whatever I'm talking about
trying to stay in shape which obviously
now I can effortlessly segue into the
Ebola panic
all right I'm sitting there watching 60
minutes
okay and I got all these famous people
telling me that they're tired of me
beating women all these women that I'm
not beating
all right I'm watching the World Series
I'm being reminded
that people lose people to cancer every
day which is which is always nice you
know when you're watching the national
Pastime Take Me Out to the Ball Game
Take Me Out to the crowd I just lost my
mother to throat cancer
I mean what the what the [__] are you
doing
I don't want to see that during the
[__] game
can we just have like the cancer Channel
like the disease Channel
you know and every once in a while I'll
[__] click over there and I'll write
a you know
send in five bucks or whatever the [__]
I gotta do do you really have to
interrupt it
am I out of my mind that I think it's
unbelievably [__] selfish
to do that to people what are they what
the [__] are they gonna do next
you gotta crash some little boy's
birthday party Happy Birthday to no more
no more she felt face first into a
birthday cake
lady he's five years old
[Laughter]
hey just in case you haven't heard
everybody it's not okay to hit a woman
just in case you're a little confused
uh cocaine is bad for you
uh just to let you know uh when somebody
dies of cancer there's people that love
them and they miss the person afterwards
and it's very painful just thought we
would remind you that while you're
trying to watch the Kansas City Royals
and the San Francisco Giants
so then you know as if all of that [__]
this is Breton circus time this is mouth
breed of time and you're coming in here
bringing up the horrors of the world
right so I'm watching uh the four
o'clock game and all they keep doing on
CBS is they keep hyping on 60 Minutes
that they're going to be talking about
three or four nurses
three of which are guys
right which means the three ladies that
were going to be nurses are now doctors
which as far as I can tell is three out
of four nurses are now men and three out
of four doctors are now women and
they're still bitching
all right and don't even tell me my math
is off on that because where the [__]
were all the female nurses they know
where to be found because they [__]
moaned and complained to get themselves
to hold the scalp and now what the [__]
are we doing we're walking around
changing bedpans and you're [__]
coming on my football to tell me not to
hit you
uh you want to take a bedpan right
across your back like wrestling with the
steel chair taking all the doctor jobs
you women got a lot of Nerf
um anyways so what do they do they start
[__] hyping um
they start hyping that they're going to
talk to these four people that were near
an Ebola patient who didn't catch Ebola
and how [__] scared they are
you know what's funny the people
actually caught Ebola how many have even
died
you know you know what a bowl is Ebola
is the Cincinnati Bengals of diseases
they started [__] strong everybody
thought they were a contender
right they knocked the ice bucket
challenge right off the map
everybody was talking about [__] ALS
Ice Bucket Challenge and then comes
Ebola right like if it was a nightclub
Ebola comes walking in a little hotter
she was a little hoary right and
everybody starts looking over at that
[__] walking into the [__] club and
then ALS is over there with the ice
bucket going wait a minute I'm doing the
wet t-shirt thing over here you guys
don't like this anymore
sorry ALS there's a better looking [__]
on the pole so not everybody's over here
looking at this [__] Ebola [__]
we're gonna be fine everybody
this is a deal let's just say
let's just say a couple hundred thousand
people die of Ebola
all right you know we we have like over
300 million people
in this country
okay
so the way I look at it it's like you
got a giant football team here Ebola
takes out 200 000 people that's like
when you make your Final Cuts in the
preseason now we got we're a little more
streamlined
all right who's kid no dude if you get
Ebola
you're weak you're a weak person
okay
you don't have the intestinal fortitude
you don't have the mental toughness
okay
to [__] survive in a world of
diseases
okay and when you get Ebola why don't
you have the [__] decency to not go
to the [__] Airport
all right
just walk down the street Into the Woods
and just bleed out by yourself like a
gentleman why can't you do that is there
a reason for that
that's my question
I'm going to take College here in 20
minutes
um
how far into this am I this [__]
absolute horse [__] uh
all right what have I talked about oh
man what's I've been watching a little
bit of hockey this is such a tough year
to try and keep up with everything I've
been really watching the World Series
though
um
I missed
most of game
four I think I did uh I was watching
something else I forget what but uh
Jesus Kansas City came back they lost
the first one for those of you not
watching
they came back they won game two and
three they're up two games to one up two
games to one right and then they go out
to you know there are actually they won
the first game in San Francisco and then
uh I was hoping that they were gonna win
either one game uh four or five and they
didn't they lost them both
it was like the giant I don't know if
there's a way to make a halftime
adjustment
but that's what it looks like the Giants
did I just think that they ran into some
tough pitching and uh
so who knows who knows but um I don't
have any sort of feeling on this series
like I don't feel like if Casey wins
game six that they're going to win game
seven I hope they do I like the Royals I
also really like the Giants too so I'm
not being a dick to people in San
Francisco it's just you know I just saw
the Giants win
2010 2012.
um and it was great to see that
um but I'd like to you know like to see
Casey get one however if the Giants win
um that's three World Series in the
2000s and they would join the Boston Red
Sox we won 0-407
in 2013.
um
because basically somebody is going to
be the Yankees of this
uh Century someone's going to be the one
who won the most [__] uh you know
team of the century basically how many
how many World Series how many how many
how many World Series do you think it's
gonna take
to be the uh the team of this century
because now that you got 30 [__]
teams what's crazy is if Kansas City
wins this year the fact that it took
them 29 years they're actually on
average mathematically
you know you got a one in 30 chance of
winning now
that they would be uh
that for them to win one in 29 years
they actually came in a year early is my
math [__] up on that I'm sure it is
I'm not the smartest guy out there
especially when it comes to the [__]
arithmetic there
um
I'm actually thinking if you won
if you want 12 maybe
if you want 12
I would think that you'd get it at this
point with 30 [__] teams that's
winning better than one a decade
um
so like right now the Red Sox are ahead
of the curve I can't believe I even get
to say that after all the [__] they went
through is they've won three so they're
actually good through the 2020s and I
think we're going to get another one
before then
um
I think the Yankees are uh
I don't know I think they're they're all
all of those teams
the Celtics the Yankees the Canadians
all of those teams that won like [__]
9 zillion titles when there was like
[__] 15 teams in the league of 10
teams in the league
you know that's over like back in the
day when the Yankees used to win titles
do you know when you won your division
that was winning the pennant they had so
few teams that there wasn't another
division you had to play forget about
two rounds of [__] baseball best four
out of seven to get to the final thing
now I'm not you know [__] with the
Yankees Legacy because it's the most
legit thing there is considering
Babe Ruth Lou Gehrig Joe DiMaggio and
Mickey Mantle no one's ever going to
have a [__] run of players like that
again you're lucky if you go back to
back
um with two unbelievable players
spaghetti about four in a row
um
but nobody's gonna win at a clip like
that again like I don't see anybody
ever catching the Yankees
like how bad the Yankees would have to
nosedive
and they're spending like you know
200 million a year I think they've
lowered their their yearly average at
this point but generally speaking they
spend roughly 200 million bucks a year
if you do that year after year after
year
uh you know you're gonna win a couple
here a couple there and you're going to
stay out front because I think the
closest
that is to them is I think the Cardinals
and they got like 11.
10 or 11 I can't remember what and that
puts them like a good 16 16 behind it's
over No One's Gonna Catch them no one's
going to catch the uh the Canadians
um
both of them are just too out and far in
front but then with basketball like I
think the Lakers are going to overtake
the Celtics just because of uh
people would rather play in LA
like Boston and LA are equally racist
um
and a lot of people don't think that
just because for some reason we get all
the attention you know despite the fact
that they have [__] riots out here
and their police are constantly [__]
murdering people
um
I would say yeah so then it just comes
down to better weather
um and celebrity [__] I mean right
there and you know
that's basically what do you want to do
you want to play in the racist town with
the bad weather and uh the potato faces
or do you want to come out here with the
plastic surgery ass and the great
weather with the racism it's a no
[__] brainer they're going to come
out here
um so
I don't know unless we go on some sort
of a [__] run that's the only real
race that there is
and for those who don't keep up on it
the Celtics have 17 and the Lakers have
15 plus a baa Championship that they
have to count
as an NBA championship for some [__]
reason I don't understand that I don't
understand how I've said it before I
don't understand how the [__] you can
win an NBA championship before the NBA
exists
it's unbelievable
but you know it's La that's what you do
I'm a director I got 16 championships
all right uh let's let's read a little
bit of advertising here oh by the way oh
by the way if um
let me get this out of the way here if
you would like to buy my uh my stand-up
comedy album and you do not live in the
continental United States
um my record is available for
international orders at
thirdmanrecords.com third manrecords.com
t-h-i-r-d
manrecords.com
uh you can order it there and um
reminders for the listeners of the
podcast the email to ask me questions
is Bill at
themmpodcast.com bill at the
mmpodcast.com
all right
let's get into uh
let's get into uh some questions here
for the week
all right
shaving in the steam room
all right what do we got here bill you
like steams after my workout I like to
take a steam what I find is people
coming in and shaving in the steam room
what the [__]
dude people are just they're [__]
animals man [__] animals there's a
sign outside no shaving but it must be
for someone else you're a quick-witted
guy what backhanded response can I give
these [__] when they come in and
start shaving
am I the most negative guy ever that I
took you're you're a quick-witted guy as
an insult hey Bill you're a quick-witted
guy why don't you write me a [__]
comeback
what am I on the writing staff of your
life here sir
um
what would you say I would sit there in
the steam be like buddy there's no
shaving in here
that's disgusting we all have to use it
what's wrong with you you [__] animal
oh look who's here
look who's here everybody it's the
lovely Mia
making appearance for the first time in
a while people thought you'd dump me get
over here
I only have one microphone don't touch
the [__]
mixer
what are you doing
I'm in the other room listening to you
screaming like a [__] about God knows
what what are you yelling about again
Mia this this podcast is uh it's an
important thing I got to bring the
energy I got to bring the labs I know
it's literally Monday morning and you're
like I'll put butter on it and [__]
screaming about pumpkin bread it's nine
in the morning what is the matter with
you
seriously and when someone calls and
asks you for a a nice quip or something
to say to somebody you get an attitude
about it
matter with you I don't know look at
look how it's written look how it's
written tell me I'm wrong there somebody
was shaving in the steam room how gross
is that that's disgusting absolutely
[__] disgusting they should literally
just put a collar around that guy and
stick him in a [__] cage take him
down to the pound yeah I mean he can
either just go straight up to him like
you said hey buddy there's no shaving in
here that sounds like exactly what we
would say you would definitely say hey
buddy in that really [__] tense way
no I would or you could like you know
what he should tell on them to the uh no
place and get them banned or you know
what you you stand up here we're getting
reports that you're you're shaving in
the steam room and Sarah well you've
been warned several times about this
we're gonna have to ask you to leave can
I have your your locker room key please
no the guy initially denies it I wasn't
shaving in there and then the guy like
gently reaches out and touches the side
of his face come on we both know
we both know there's no way your face is
going to be that smooth unless you're
shaving you know what the guy you guys
should do is just stand up and start
peeing on his leg
now this is what you do you say what
yeah no you say Sir there's no shaving
in here and if he has an attitude then
you pee on his leg and then you both get
kicked out and it's just then you make
the news like that TMZ a man was shaving
this isn't gonna make the show let me
get a tighter shirt the this man was
shaving in the state room with this
other guy he got so many peas on his leg
no way no way that didn't happen
that's my TMZ impression
stupid [__]
it [__] with all those
all those standing around
I do uh I watch it from time to time to
get caught up on the on the celebrity
tee I have never seen however long it
seems like it's an hour long an hour
long of nothing yeah yeah just watching
people coming out of restaurants
you know hey Sean Pat what do you think
about ebola and he's just like what
I just had some muscles
oh Cleo Cleo wants to be in the podcast
too all right all right all right all
right it was going off the rails it's
going off the rails here
the original [__] block anytime we hug
the dog comes over like I want to be a
part of it
go lie down Mommy
get over there
get over there stupid
don't call the dog stupid oh that dog I
[__] love that dog you don't even
understand all right I don't understand
yeah you don't understand I do
understand the way you throw yourself on
top of her and go oh Cleo as loud as
possible it's one of my favorite things
to do you can't stop doing it
and you do it constantly throughout the
day you do it like 10 times a day I'm
not exaggerating
I'm not going to defend myself it's like
how do you not go over and hug your dog
that's what I do I always go all right
she she sees me coming over She lays
down her side and I just grab her and I
squeeze her and I scream oh
and who takes her for a hike every
[__] day me yeah you do but you also
like literally you walk into the room
and she's like up on her feet and she's
like
like you you're giving the dog your
energy your manic energy
that's true
psycho what do you want from me but you
know what I don't shave in the steam
room so what would I say to this guy I
would say uh I'd be like buddy there's
no shaving in here
that's [__] gross yeah
yeah what's wrong with you little stupid
whiskers are gonna be there on the floor
you [__] animal dude I I swear to God
I swear to God
the the [__] animals that go into
steam rooms
[__] animals
[__] guy like cleaning these toenails
or his dead skin off of his feet just
sitting there scrubbing it
yeah no you know something I
had a people that go into steam rooms I
think the rest of us we need to speak up
we're just sitting there silent and
they're not saying anything what the
[__] is wrong with you dude that's gross
sitting there yelling at somebody you
both got your dicks out I'll tell you
nothing 's flapping around
remaining positive
three-year-old reaching recent college
graduate who's dealing with a bit of
depression having never dated finding it
hard did I write this having never dated
finding it hard to get a job and having
no actual goal in life I'm finding it
hard to keep motivated to do anything I
normally eat well and go to the gym but
that's the only healthy habit I have I
want to be enjoying my 20s but because
I've accomplished nothing not even
having formed any relationship with any
girl it's been hard to smile and remain
positive do you get into these sorts of
funks and what advice would you have to
get out of it any advice from you or the
lovely Mia would honestly make a major
impact on my life no pressure yeah Buddy
Jesus um
yeah I literally could have written that
at 23 years old I was basically in the
uh
essentially the same boat
um had no [__] I was still living at
home had no girlfriend I commuted all
the way through college I didn't have
any college friends never went to any of
those parties or any of that type of
[__]
um
and I was actually flailing wondering
what the [__] I was going to do with my
life I tried sales I worked in
warehousing I had a job at a dental
office and none of it was making me
excited about going to work and I
started thinking like ah [__] am I going
to be that guy
that guy that just does a [__] job
that he hates and um
I don't know I just started every day
I don't know just trying to think what I
wanted
what did I want and um don't look at it
with judgment or think that something's
impossible like whatever you want to do
to be sitting there thinking like oh I
can't do that I could never do it you
can't
you can't I am an absolute [__] and if
I can make something happen you
definitely can I would I would say that
I don't like how you laugh when I said
I'm a [__] you are a [__] but I think
you just gave really really perfect
advice
that's great advice
you got to figure out yeah what is it
that you really really enjoy doing and
maybe there's a way to actually make a
living at it like Bill yeah this is what
you just start doing it
you just start
[__] doing it and then eventually it
turns in to your job
and all you do is just
I think what most people do is like say
they're thinking like I don't know pick
a job
that's [__] uh you're like oh I could
never do that I'll just keep it in
entertainment say you wanted to
um
get into like um broadcasting I guess
announcing games and you start thinking
like oh my God I want to announce NFL
games how the [__] do I get there
so you start
you know I would think you'd start doing
high school games
Little League games I would do anything
I would just if no one was hiring me I
would just show up at Little League
games with a [__] sport coat on and
set up a table and I would just start
doing it I would go down to pick up
basketball games I just that's not
creepy at all and I would just start now
and just showing up at the little kids
game like here I am
I know because now because his
pedophiles there's always been
pedophiles what am I and here I am I'm
gonna what start molesting a kid is
everyone's sitting there I would just
start doing the game like it was a major
league baseball game the parents would
love it you could go down to like the uh
the basketball courts I would just
anything just just to be doing it that's
like your Open Mic so I'm not getting
paid I'm learning how to do this [__]
and then I don't know
start taking some classes at a
broadcasting School you just every part
of your day becomes announcing you know
right I when I had day jobs I used to
sit there doing the job and I would be
any any funny [__] idea ahead I would
just write it down
and um
and then I would go try it out somewhere
and I just kept doing it and doing it
and doing it and do you just you just
start marching towards it and you don't
look at like well hey I just [__] I'm
I'm doing high school games I'll never
get to the NFL like most people don't
get there because they want it in a week
Dude that [__] helicopters are gonna
fly into the [__] house around here
they're crazy
I don't know if you guys could just hear
that [__]
um
they uh
yeah you just every single day you just
you just I don't know look at this
stupid ass podcast
I just kept doing it every Monday and
all of a sudden you know I got a bunch
of listeners I'm curious about because
I'm trying to you know I'm always trying
to like read between the lines and he
goes I normally eat well and go to the
gym but that's the only quote-unquote
healthy habit I have what does that mean
well I don't want to start I'm just I'm
curious as why that got thrown in there
because I don't know if that means that
there's things that he's doing that he
is not healthy because the rest of it
doesn't really I don't know I normally
well and go to the gym that's the only
healthy habit I have like it's or it's
like the only thing like habit I have
it's just like working out and going to
the gym but I don't have any other like
things like just the healthy in quotes
is uh concerns me well I think he's
really hard on himself so he's got to
lighten up on himself so even when he's
doing something even when he's doing
something positive he still puts it in
quotes he won't give himself credit for
that it sounds like you maybe he had
some negative parents who uh told you
the world was a lot more difficult than
it is I would uh I'd also work on like
just paying attention to the thoughts in
your head that's how because I was never
clinically depressed but I was
definitely I had definitely bouts of
depression and funks and that type of
thing I felt like [__] yesterday when I
was watching the game and I did uh uh
100 push-ups and you know three sets
okay I'm not gonna actually like
actually drop down I would have had a
heart attack I don't know I did I did
set a three and I got to 100. 105
actually sets of 35 all right you folks
um
no but I immediately felt better
I immediately felt better so and also
you're 23 years old you have a long long
time to figure out what it is that you
want to do for the rest of your life you
know what I mean and it's probably gonna
change several times so maybe you just
graduated college and you're like oh I
majored in business I don't want to get
into business I really want to you know
be a veterinarian or something like that
and I think that Bill's right you should
then I want to do it I would immediately
start picking up a roadkill off of the
side of the road and I try to see if I
could bring it back to life
having it so by Reviving that uh dead
cat on the freeway no no just yeah
you're fine you're 23 you got your whole
life ahead of you you know it could be
worse dude you could be in a
relationship and you [__] knocked her
up and now you're tied to her for the
rest of your [__] life and then you
got to go get a job at some place you
want to work at so the fact that you
don't have anything going on in your
life is [__] awesome
there's nothing holding you back you can
just now you can you actually get to
decide you know I mean people would want
to be in your [__] position 23 no
girlfriend
you know no [__] mortgage no [__]
none of that stuff it's just you don't
[__] you know figure out what you
want to do and go after it and uh tell
that negative thought you had to go [__]
yourself there you go that was like a Dr
Phil episode there you go that solves
all your problems
when we come back I yell at more men you
work out uh yeah just work on yourself
the wrestle the rest will come together
don't worry about the girl part yet just
get get your own [__] together I already
said that
why did you feel like you you keep
trying to say you keep trying you keep
trying to say like you keep trying to be
the person who says the last thing this
is my podcast I wrap it up my hair I
wrap it you wanted me to come in here
you wanted me to come in here I did so
stop giving me [__] read the next
question all right
artificial intelligence also known as
Bill Burr
oh Jesus the artificial intelligence and
it's if as long as there's intelligence
in there I'll take it and it's impact on
Humanity
Dill dear Bill boo Baggins
what are your thoughts on Tesla founder
Elon musk's warnings on artificial
intelligence I just love the fact that
you'd think that I actually read it he
said that through recursive
self-improvement simple tasks like
preventing spam could lead to an AI
determining humans are the problem
it's just like a Sci-Fi script
I know okay yeah I get it I'm totally
interested but I don't know what's going
on here recursive self-improvement means
it could reason with itself
oh this is uh like when you you make a
computer that like has emotions like a
human being well no it's like like he's
talking about we're trying to get rid of
spam and email and stuff but whatever
program is like wait there's a human
being behind the spam there's a there's
a human being behind the um Nigerian
prince scheme or the oh my God friend
I'm trapped in Denmark and I've had my
passport and all my money like taken
from me and I don't think that is I
think he's talking AI
simple tasks like preventing spam could
lead to AI artificial intelligence as a
computer yeah it's a robot determining
humans are the problem yeah okay so how
is there a guy in Nigeria recursive
self-improvement saying like it's
realizing that human beings are behind
the spam in your email like there's
someone oh I see what you're saying I
see what you're saying okay sorry about
that
um
it's going to be a long one
[Laughter]
recursive self-improvement means it
could reason with itself and
incrementally improve to overcome
obstacles that prevent it from
fulfilling its objectives I listened to
previous podcasts and you've mentioned
you think there would be a backdoor
built into any AI machine robots by the
powers that be however using the
recursive self-improvement that Elan
mentioned in AI could eventually reason
with itself that a back door preventing
it from fulfilling its mandate must be
ignored or overcome
Elon Musk is very intelligent having
found founded Paypal SpaceX and Tesla as
well as playing a key role in Solar City
so I don't think his concern should be
taken lightly here's a book that delves
into the subject in more detail because
I know you're a deep thinker see what
I'm saying they're all giving me [__] oh
that's funny
our final invention artificial
intelligence and the end of the human
era thanks for your uh for your [__]
opinion
um
is this something like sort of like 1984
type [__] like you know no 1984 was
humans on humans
oh see there's that's already going on
that's already going on where someone
who was our Ally yesterday is now the
enemy and then the enemy is now the Ally
and vice versa and all that type of [__]
so this is basically
means are getting so smart that they're
gonna eventually like take over
yeah here's the thing about machines Nia
they don't have legs
the robots might maybe that's his whole
point like the robots the robots I'm
afraid of but just like a computer right
it's like you don't have legs and you
haven't built an umbilical cord plugged
into that [__] wall over there and I
will snip that [__] and I will dump
water on you and that's the end of you
dump water on you yeah go dump water on
your computer see what happens but
aren't they talking about making robots
that'll be able to like surpass all of
that [__] and that's the scary part
about it it's like you don't want to
give them too much intelligence because
like he was saying they'll learn that
like hey wait I've got this whole back
door thing and [__] that back door yeah
well because they're gonna evolve beyond
that here's the thing
what people don't understand her did you
ever see that movie her with Joaquin
Phoenix there was too much red
[Laughter]
it's just too much red he was the only
one really that wore red but anyway go
on
anyways this is what I feel
people are acting like this just some
nerdy scientist I'm going to make these
artificial intelligent [__] it is
it's rich people and rich people
at the top want to phase out us the sick
of us like we are an inconvenience to
them with our complaints and our needs
they want us to shut the [__] up they
want us to all to be making [__]
slippers for them for [__] 50 cents a
month they want to have all the cars
they want like when I went to the
farmer's market yesterday right
to add to my effeminate weekend of
pumpkin bread and driving a Prius uh
speaking of which you need to store your
strawberries more correctly because
they're just sitting out on the counter
and they're going to go bad you know why
you know why I left them out there
because you leave your strawberries out
on the counter because they're not
organic I went to a farmer's market and
they actually just have regular you have
to ask them is this organic and they'll
be well you know our form is the blah
blah blah they can't even handle 200
people the grocery stores can't handle
200 [__] people walking into a
parking lot to buy some goddamn eggs
they even have to get that money like
they just they don't they they want they
want it all the people at the top so can
I have those strawberries if you're not
going to eat them
let's see did you hear did you hear that
back and forth this is why we deserve to
get [__] taken over right here
because you can't keep people on you
just give a [__] about the strawberries
I'm talking about the overall picture
man I don't care if the strawberries are
organic or not that's not my cause right
now I'm just I like strawberries so I'm
trying to stay on topic with this oh yes
yeah let's say um can you come near the
mic please so basically what is this
person asking you so he's asking me if
I'm worried about artificial
intelligence I actually think that
there's human beings behind it and it's
gonna play out like the classic like
Frankenstein where you build it and then
it comes back and kicks the [__] out of
you but like
I think you know a lot of people looking
at us like like human beings as a
collective what what are we doing we
aren't doing anything you're Expendable
I'm Expendable we're an annoyance to
them what what the reason why we're
still here is because we pay taxes we
pay interest they got their foot on the
back of our [__] neck and we're
helping to buy like some more [__]
gold coins for them every single month
but eventually but they but the thing
the the big flaw with human beings is
that we complain
and we pay attention and we go hey that
isn't fair and I think super rich people
are sick of it and it'd be great
wouldn't it be great if we could somehow
get them to just work not [__] and not
have to pay him at all what is the
solution let's make some [__] robots
yeah but then you know the robots would
be great but then who are we gonna
[__] pull over to the side of the
road and have them suck our dicks in the
back of our limos well we got to make
them more lifelike so they're going to
try to make these lifelike robots that
will do whatever the [__] they want and
suck their dicks and work out in the
fields and all that [__] [__] but
then eventually they're going to get
overrun so you are concerned about
artificial intelligence then no I'm not
concerned about it because there's
nothing to stop it
I just was talking to you about it and
your main focus is the strawberries
right there that little microcosm of
that [__] conversation is why I
tapped out a conspiracy theory I will
not talk I mean I'll just I'll do it on
this podcast because I don't listen to
somebody else
um either saying that's [__] [__]
or this or that or that or here's my
even crazier Theory because I'm nuts
everybody's [__] nuts uh everything
has I the thing I believe everything has
a beginning a middle and an end and uh
human beings are no different and uh you
know whatever I'm gonna die anyway so
what the [__] do I hear you're talking
about rich people being annoyed by
non-rich people I was just reading
something online that was talking about
a deer Prudence you know like an advice
column over the weekend or something and
there was a rich person that was saying
you know I live in a very wealthy
community and um you know there are
billionaires and stuff around us for the
most part like the street where I live
is just doctors and lawyers and things
anyway we just noticed that every
Halloween there are all these people
from the poor neighborhoods that come in
and like you know trick-or-treating and
ask for candy and I just really feel
like we're already doing so much you
know and paying so many taxes for this
that and the other like does Halloween
now have to become a social service and
basically the advice giver was like wow
like you are an [__] cool like it's
Halloween it's kids and candy like are
you really trying to make a bigger
statement about Society or over
Halloween wait a minute wait a minute
you canceled Halloween at our house not
because of any sort of like class issue
I canceled Halloween because people were
coming over here acting like [__]
morons I don't want 40 year old people
just standing there dead-eyed looking at
me like what's up with the candy or high
school kids who don't isn't isn't that
what this guy's saying in a way didn't
have the decency all right well then
just take the age of the people out of
it high school's kids who don't even
have the decency to come in a [__]
costume who don't even have the decency
to say trick or treat they stand there
staring at you you would get an Applause
break in this guy's gated community
right now yeah yeah but it's like coming
to college you don't like women of color
but this one makes sense yeah exactly
don't come in here and be like [__]
weird about it I don't care if whoever
any kid that comes into the neighborhood
from wherever they are Halloween is
awesome in that way because it's cute
fun kids they're excited about going out
there with their parents their parents
are like say thank you say like it's a
lovely thing you give out candy to eight
o'clock at night and then you turn the
light out exactly that's that's the
thing I just the the kids that come with
no costumes and it's like I'm afraid
they're gonna egg the house so I feel
like I have to give them candy like it's
[__] it's annoying I just want
people to to reciprocate the the spirit
of Halloween okay if I ask you a
question handing out candy I need a
little something from YouTube can you
imagine you're so broke
that you look forward to Halloween so
you can [__] walk up and try to get a
candy bar from another adult do you guys
have [__] demoralizing that is I'm
saying this to it but we're getting off
track we're getting off track but it's
but there's also freeloaders out there
too but this this is the thing this is
the thing Nene
is what that guy is saying is how a lot
of rich people view people who aren't
Rich we uh we should be privileged that
we're in there
um
presence yeah like that type of guy that
type of guy do you think that that type
of guy
would give a [__] if the rest of the
world got phased out and was replaced by
robots that would work for him
would never go on strike and were so
lifelike that he could [__] them
and it would feel like he was with the
person I mean that's their idea of
Utopia because they're [__] sociopath
not all of them but generally speaking
this sociopaths
is that the beginning of most uh yes
sci-fi novels and it's like the
convenience of it it's great and then
the robots eventually take over yeah
because they're smarter than us and
they've somehow been able to continue to
evolve beyond our program right which is
kind of like what her was about a little
bit and then yeah and then basically
what happens is then they forget that
like they don't know how to uh
well actually a sci-fi movie what would
happen was there'd be a few humans that
they allowed to live and then we work
for them it's basically the Planet of
the Apes [__] template over and over
and over again and then we come back and
either Mark Wahlberg or uh Morris
Chestnut or one of those [__] guys
where's Chestnut please would be
um
is that really his name yes it is that
sounds like the name of a cat the worst
Chestnut yeah it does like somebody who
like lives with cats and not people and
then all of a sudden just like and gives
them like real names then over there now
that's Morris chestnuts trapping hunking
chocolate piece of gorgeousness that's
in movies
you've never said that about me all
right uh uh advice okay I sound like
Aisha I sound like Aisha on Archer nope
is um all right advice hey Bill fellow
redhead here in need of some advice
another Freckle face there I'm 21 years
old and after two years of college I
decided to drop out because I didn't I
simply didn't see a future that would
make me happy smart move you need to
regroup figure out what you want I know
I may have burned a bridge here and made
an irrational decision but I really
couldn't take any more of it since I
felt like I was wasting my time and
effort and my dad's hard-earned money
since he paid for the tuition my parents
aren't exactly ecstatic but they are not
Furious either I have a job and all that
stuff and I've been playing guitar for
nearly four years now so I'm not bad but
not nearly as good as I want to be
considering I like metal and crap like
that I'd really appreciate some advice
on whether or not I made a terrible
decision because part of me
said I did another said I didn't uh
should I simply be more open-minded
about my future or should I pursue my
dream of being a musician even though
that's extremely
uh far off I think he meant to say far
off and unrealistic deep down I feel
like I'll figure something out because I
always have in the past
when something big comes up and whatnot
thanks in advance really like your work
and your podcast you cheer me up with
your jokes when life gets me down all
right yeah dude no my music's the guy
why don't you go to music school you're
21 you dropped out of college maybe
because uh it just wasn't they didn't
offer the kind of curriculum you were
into
so you said hang on a second I've been
playing guitar for nearly four years now
so I'm not bad but nearly as good as I
want to be considering I like metal and
crap like that why don't why don't we
sort of take this back to the first
advice that you gave why don't you find
like tell me what to do why don't you
shut up you look gorgeous this morning
by the way thank you see how you do that
people oh [__]
um anyways
I meant it I meant it go to uh why
doesn't it go to Music School here's the
deal enroll in a music program so you
can get better
um play guitar keep playing guitar every
second it's like the first advice you
can give Play here's the big here's the
big thing in this email
is that you're having my impression of
red metal
um
this is why school is so [__] up this
guy is literally ignoring his heart
staying in school because he's following
the [__] herd this guy wants to play
guitar dude I let me ask you this how
happy are you
when you're playing guitar when you're
doing other activities are you thinking
I wish I was playing guitar that that's
what you're supposed to be doing
on whatever level and if you think
you're not good enough like you've been
playing guitar for four years you can be
a rhythm guitarist in a band
how cool is Malcolm Young he wrote all
those [__] riffs for AC DC the poor
guy's got them
sick now man sucks
um but anyways like uh
that's what you do join a [__] band
just join a band go down a music store
they always have those [__] things a
little little we were looking for a
rhythm guitarist looking for this yeah
that was a little fun just do that
and just make your whole life about
music
give guitar lessons just your whole
[__] life becomes music and then
eventually you're gonna be you're going
to be in the music world you might end
up uh who knows being a producer for
albums you might end up being an abandon
makes it you might end up managing but
you're going to be in the music business
you're going to be around music which is
what you love okay I think there's a
reason that you did it I think the the
reason why you're thinking oh maybe I
should have done that is because 99 of
your friends are all you know if I got
two more years of college and I majored
in this and I'm gonna go out in the job
world I'm gonna get married have two and
a half kids blah blah which is [__]
fine if that's what you want to do but
you do not want to do this you want to
play guitar so you made a great decision
congratulations and the balls that that
took
to [__] walk away from college I
didn't have the balls to do that I felt
like I had to finish I got to get a
degree I got to get a degree and uh I
should have just went right down to a
comedy club I knew from the time I was
14 years old and I wanted to be a
stand-up comic and it took me until I
was 24 to finally get the balls up to do
it so you're way ahead of the game
you're gonna be fine all right and I
gotta go to work here so that's that's
gonna be it here for the podcast thank
you everybody for listening thank you to
the lovely Nia for dropping in you're
welcome the next time I'm coming come on
here though we need to talk about some
of the stuff I heard you screaming about
earlier about what something about women
and something ignorant that you say
which is I guess it's a [__] jokes
what did I say they said the bedpan
smashed across yeah yeah you think
that's that's a wrestling reference were
you talking about ebola or something
like that too I don't know what it was
or something like that something along
those lines no speaking of that ignorant
I gotta I gotta I gotta read some
advertising
um